converts students into fans wow your
peers and even more than that you can
find a way to change the flow world all
by teaching really amazing workshops
here's how hi Drex here from drexfactor
POI sharing with you the love of boy
spinning and flow Arts to benefit your
body and brain I have been teaching and
Performing flow Arts now for a decade
and a half and I would love to share
with you some of my favorite tips for
planning and putting together workshops
but before we dive in I just want to
give a quick shout out to the Friends of
the channel big thanks to dark monk fire
Mecca flow fests flow toys juggling
calling pyro Terra light toys spin balls
and Ultra POI for helping to make the
videos on this channel possible you can
learn more about all of these awesome
companies and the work that they're
doing to support flow artists like
yourself by checking out the links that
I've got down in the description of this
video and special thanks to the
non-business friend of the channel Becca
pekonen thank you so much for supporting
my channel my work and my mission so as
I'm recording this it is in August of
2023 and I think this puts us roughly
somewhere between two-thirds to three
quarters of the way through the 2023
Festival season
um just a few days ago I got back from
teaching at Great Lakes flow Retreats
and my mind is swimming because one of
the requests that I got there was to
teach a workshop and or create a video
on how to create a workshop so your wish
is my command education is a Cornerstone
of what I consider my mission with flow
Arts to be so it seems kind of up my
alley to talk a little bit about how we
can create the best version of that
experience for others so in this video
I'm going to cover four different
aspects of how you plan and prepare for
a workshop ranging from picking out your
topic to structuring the material
preparing it and finally what to do the
day of only in DC do you get interrupted
making a video by having a helicopter
going over ahead of you
okay so let's start off by talking about
topic I know this is a thing a lot of
people struggle with because of course
how do you pick something that people
are going to want to learn from you of
course once I sit down to do this it
starts raining now me personally I think
that a great Workshop answers at least
one of five specific questions number
one what's something that I wish that I
had learned earlier on in my flow
Journey that is was there a specific
trick technique or approach to spending
that you wish somebody had introduced
you to earlier something that could have
made your life easier or that was
particularly insightful in a way that
stuck with you for a while number two
what is something that I think everybody
should know in the flow Arts is there a
major Gap that a lot of people have in
their learning is there something that
you think everybody ought to have in
their wheelhouse something that just
makes their flow Journey better or
easier in the grand scheme of things
number three what's something that I'd
like to see more of is there a
particular thing that you think has a
lot of potential is there a particular
thing that we somehow lost at some point
in the past in the flow world and you'd
like to see it come back hey a workshop
is a great opportunity to introduce more
people to it number four
is there something that people are
frequently asking you about a lot of US
post videos online is there something
that people single out in your videos
that they say hey that was really cool
hey guess what that's an excellent
opportunity to build a workshop around
and finally kind of the nuclear option
here is just looking and saying what
people are asking about online you know
you could check and see if there's a lot
of people asking how do I do this or how
do I do that in one of the online groups
and quite frankly if there isn't a post
already like that you can always add one
do a post in POI chat or one of the many
other flow arts groups and ask what is
something that you would really like to
learn in a workshop because some people
learn better face to face than they do
in videos and the answers might surprise
you okay the radar seems to indicate
that this is either going to stay light
rain or it is not going to continue at
all so everybody keep your fingers
crossed for me here okay so next up
let's talk a little bit more about how
you structure this Workshop once you've
got your topic picked out I personally
think that you should never ever plan to
teach more than say three or four tricks
Max in a class there's a few reasons for
this number one is that the students are
just going to burn out on taking in new
information especially if the tricks are
really challenging you're probably going
to get maybe two or three tricks in
before people's capacity to bring in new
information is just going to kind of
reach its limit number two
try and make sure that the knowledge
that you're conveying to people flows
into each other
there's a big problem that a lot of us
have when we start spinning where we
think of individual topics or tricks as
almost being like separate boxes that
exist in isolation from each other one
of those big breakthroughs that happens
for people when they're learning how to
spin is being able to connect the dots
on those things and be able to put the
boxes together and stack them like Lego
blocks knowledge in your workshops
should be the same thing the knowledge
you learn for trick a should flow into
the knowledge that is necessary for
trick B make sure that the connections
between all of these things are
glaringly obvious to your Workshop
attendees and that will create a better
experience for them number three
be aware that people learn best when
they're receiving knowledge through
three different channels so make sure
that you have methods built in to be
able to reinforce knowledge verbally
visually and kinesthetically make sure
that everybody is going through those
steps and people will retain the
knowledge a lot better also plan time to
get newbies up to speed people will drop
into your classes for one of three
reasons and of course the reason we all
hope for is that they're super keen on
the information that you're going to
teach and they're showing up ready
willing and able to assimilate it and
yes some people will show up with that
in mind however a very significant
number will not they will show up for
one of two other reasons number one is
that they're familiar with you from
online and they want to meet you and get
to know you better
number three quite frankly a lot of
people at the festivals are probably
interested in a tool go around to one of
the vendors and pick up the tool for the
first time and they're really keen on
learning something right away and yours
is the first workshop on the schedule
after they have picked up that prop and
they will walk in and probably have
absolutely no idea what it's about and
have absolutely no prerequisite
knowledge always assume when your
students are walking into your Workshop
that they have no prerequisites under
under their belt that you are starting
them from scratch yes that makes the
more advanced workshops harder and yes
this is also why more advanced workshops
tend to have very poor attendance make
sure that you're building in time at the
very beginning to catch the newbies up
assume that you're going to have to
explain every single concept that you're
covering in great depth do not take
anything for granted you also want to
build in time for rests and jokes as you
are facilitating people getting new
knowledge make sure you're building in
time for them to take a little while to
work on it very few people are able to
do something the first time that they're
shown it
make sure that you're explaining and not
just showing
and also make sure that you've got a
couple jokes written in there too uh to
help break the mood and break the
tension and everything it gives people's
brains just a little bit of a chance to
relax as they are accumulating new
information and this is a really
important thing you want to make sure
that you're not covering so much
information in your Workshop that it
can't be summarized in five minutes
generally speaking you want to finish up
your workshops with a little recap you
want to have your uh the people who are
taking your Workshop pull out their
phones and record a quick video if you
can't if you can't summarize it in five
minutes you're covering too much
information cut it down okay so that was
a lot of information about how to
prepare your material as well as should
be a good Workshop is something that
requires a lot of planning and prep and
a lot of refinement too so let's talk
real right quickly about how to refine
that material before you ever get in to
teach it so I highly recommend doing a
dry run of your Workshop whether you get
together a small handful of friends or
perhaps like you could do a live stream
on your social media basically run
through the material and see as you're
doing it how it flows yes pun intended
you want to watch out for moments where
your students get either a little lost
or a little stuck those are moments that
you need to pay very careful attention
to is there something that needs more
explanation is there something that you
should anticipate and incorporate into
how you present that trick or material
um and this is also another opportunity
to find out if you're covering too much
material are people struggling to catch
up with all of the stuff that you're
doing I know that from like the early
part of my career I was really insecure
about not teaching enough stuff and
believe me uh the challenge that you
have is not providing enough material
the challenge that you have is providing
the best material you can inside the
time that you're allotted don't stress
about quantity stress about quality if
people run out of there with three or
four moves they're super excited about
rather than 10 moves that they barely
remember you've done a better job also
use this information to help work up a
second draft of the material and use
that to inform how you're going to
actually teach it once you get to the
event itself okay so the final thing we
have to cover then is what happens the
day of the workshop job how to prepare
for the actual teaching of it before you
go into your workshops
be well rested be sober uh make sure
that you can be mentally present for
your students I know that flow festivals
and flow events are really exciting and
you want to go do all the things you've
been hired to do a job here make sure
that you are showing up and you are
giving your students the best that you
have to offer if for no other reason
then
um you can think of your workshops as
also being essentially an opportunity to
pick up new fans and new customers do
not squander that opportunity number two
be on time
program your Workshop times and location
into your phone make sure that you are
setting an alarm for yourself that is 15
minutes before you're supposed to go
teach class if you are wandering around
and you need to run back to your tent
and set the alarm for 30 minutes instead
make sure that you are there before
anybody else respect people's time
please here's another big one it feels
great getting to teach a workshop I know
it does the moment you step into that
Workshop the focus is on the students
it's not on you figure out what your
students need from you and be there to
deliver it for them this can take the
form of taking extra time with students
that are really struggling we all get
drawn into the whole thing of you know
the people that get it are kind of
feeding our egos and the people that
aren't make us a little bit insecure
about how good a teacher we are
put that ego aside spend the time with
the people that are struggling they need
it more than anyone else also make sure
that you're doing that recap at the end
there are so many studies showing that
when you summarize knowledge again at
the end of a lesson it is way more
likely to stick with people have them
take out their phones and record another
big one and this is going to be a really
unpopular suggestion but make sure that
you're building in at least 30 minutes
to an hour afterwards to recover what
does recovery look like go find
someplace quiet chill out for a while
read a book play a game give yourself
time to recover afterwards if you don't
you're gonna have to find that recovery
time some at some other time and it
might be during that weekend it might be
after that weekend but you will have to
pay the piper at some point so
um personally I think it's better to do
that right afterwards and nourish your
needs right then not the least of which
because you might be teaching another
Workshop later on in the day and finally
easily the most important tip I will
give you in this video
bring a notebook with you to the
workshop
here's why at the end of the workshop
tell everybody that you want their
feedback have them write down their
email addresses in your notebook
I have a Google form that I send around
to people who've taken my workshops that
I specifically use to tailor the
material in my workshops my most popular
workshops uh probably took me around
like five to six years of taking in
feedback and trying new things and
trying different things before they
arrived in their current forms and the
thing is is like looking at the feedback
that I've gotten over the years I can
absolutely point to the material having
Ebbs and flows in terms of its
Effectiveness and now the workshops that
I teach I consistently get top marks on
because I tried out things that didn't
work and I heard from my students the
things that did and that showed me what
needed to be cut and what needed to be
added and add a bonus the email
addresses that you collect are also the
beginnings of an email list for you it's
good for building your brand it's good
for building your business and it is
absolutely necessary for improving your
workshops I will include a link to the
workshop feedback template that I use as
a link down in the description of this
video for those of you who are
interested in adding this to your own
Workshop all right cool so with all that
said let me get out of the rain now
shall I cool so I hope these tips help
those of you out there that are
interested in teaching workshops
one of the tips that I didn't mention
here that I probably should have is that
a great way to prepare for teaching
workshops is to go take other people's
workshops pay attention to what they do
that feels really effective and pay
attention to aspects of the class where
notice the places where you lose
interest or start getting bored or your
mind starts wandering and take a moment
to figure out like why did that happen
in that moment and what could a
instructor do to re-center the class in
those moments what was the best Workshop
you ever took what made it such a good
Workshop leave me a comment and let me
know and let me know if any of these
tips in particular jumped out to you and
really made you think about teaching
differently in the meantime thanks so
much for watching make sure to like
share comment and subscribe to help
other people find this video and help my
channel grow this video would not be
possible we're not for the kind sport of
all of these lovely people right here
these are my flow patrons over on
patreon they and the people who sit down
in the description helps make this video
and all the videos on my channel
possible thank you one and all for your
very generous support and if you out
there watching are interested in
supporting my work but are not currently
supporters you can become a supporter by
heading on over to patreon.com
drexfactorpoi and signing up there you
can get access to a whole host of
awesome rewards but even better than
that you'll be supporting me in my
mission to bring POI spinning and flow
Arts to the whole wide world so go check
that out please and thank you and if you
you would like to check out more videos
I've done that are resources on Flow
festivals and other aspects of flow
culture I will go ahead and leave a link
to a playlist of those videos down in
the description as well as up here on
screen if you're watching on YouTube
also the YouTube algorithm thinks that
you might like this top video here
because it is popular amongst viewers of
my channel so maybe give that a look as
well thanks so much for watching make
sure to have a good day and I will see
you real soon with a new video peace